The following
content is provided
under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: And [INAUDIBLE]
them for next week.
So for Monday just
to really settle
expectations for what
we're doing on Mondays,
we are doing rehearsals
of presentations.
You do not need to do
the demo of your game
part of the rehearsal.
You do need to do
the actual talk.
That means we're asking for
the visual slides, any visuals
you're going to use.
Go through the full talk as
if you're going to do it.
Don't try to speed through it.
If it's in outline
mode, then maybe
you're testing the
actual material
that you're going
to be going through.
Please pay attention to all the
talks that you're listing to.
Give them feedback.
Give the other teams feedback
about what they're saying.
We will be here basically
kind of like The Voice
but without the
cool chairs, letting
you know what we think
about your stuff.
Yes.
A great way to get a good
grade for the presentation
is to listen to all the
feedback and make changes,
so keep that in mind.
AUDIENCE: Just as a
suggestion, even though you
don't have to demo
your stuff, it
might be a good idea just to
bring the computer [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: And test
the hardware just
to make sure that the
screen resolution works out,
you can go full
screen, you don't
have that Google Chrome has
taking over your entire screen.
Hit Escape.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So make sure the
game works, but you
don't need to actually play it.
Works in a period of time.
Time length for these
presentations-- each team
is given 20 minutes.
You will be timed.
We will flag you once
you hit 20 minutes.
That's total for the entire
presentation including
the demo.
Limit the game-playing
part of your presentation
to no more than 10 minutes.
Anything more than
10 minutes, we're
going to make a note of
that, but please keep it
under 10 minutes.
It can be as short as you like.
You could have someone
play the entire game.
You can have someone play
just one part of the game.
You will have
somebody who has not
played your game before
playing the game live on stage,
so that's also a test of ours.
Time for the actual
slides part of your talk
has to be at least 10 minutes,
so 10 is a good suggestion.
Five minutes of demo, 15 minutes
of talk is also fine, as well.
After you're finished
with that talk,
we're going to open
it to Q&A from people
in the group in the room,
and that will include us.
So rehearsal is give
your presentation.
We won't do the Q&A.
We'll just do feedback.
Final presentations
are the real deal.
It is being recorded, of course.
We are still figuring out if
we're going to live stream it.
Please invite your friends on
Wednesday the 10th to come.
We're sending out invites
to a bunch of people,
to get some of our
local developer friends
to come in and talk, and also
some folks from our department
and from some of the
other game design classes
to come and watch.
Attendance for those two
days-- so attendance for Monday
is going to be normal like
we've just been doing it.
Attendance for Wednesday--
come in at 1:00, please.
Let us know if you're
going to be late,
like email the video
game bosses list if you
are going to be
late on Wednesday
for the final presentations.
We'll keep the sheet
in the back of the room
so you can sign in as
you come into the room.
Anything I'm missing
from any of that?
And then at the end of
all the presentations,
we'll probably going to end
up with about 30 minutes left
of class, so you can
open up your computers
and have people play
your games if you like.
Totally not required,
but it tends
to be fun when we do that.
Cool.
So if there's no questions
about any of that,
we are going to do
our last lecture.
We've invited Sean Baptiste
from Fire Hose Games
to talk to us about community
management, marketing,
and all sorts of stuff,
and basically how do you
get people to play your games.
And after he's done,
attendance will be back open.
SEAN BAPTISTE: Cool.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for having me here.
This is great.
My name is Sean Baptiste.
I'm a 10-year veteran of
the video game industry.
My first job was
at Harmonix, which
was a huge AAA sort of deal.
And now I'm at a small
indie game studio
right here in Cambridge that was
started by some former game lab
alumni, Ethan Fenn and Sharat
Chat and Eitan Glinert.
I think I should probably start
how I got into the industry
in the first place.
I don't have a tech
background whatsoever.
I came up through theater.
I was a theater major, and one
thing I've realized in my years
is that there are a lot of
theater majors in video games.
I've been thinking
about it a lot.
I think a lot of it is that
video games and theater
both have an interactive
element where there's
interplay between the
audience and the creator
that film doesn't
have necessarily.
And I think a lot
of theater people
drift towards there
when they realize
there's no money to be
made whatsoever in theater.
That's how I made it.
So I was working
in film and I was
working in theater and
stuff and I got sick,
and just the only
game I could play
was Amplitude, which was
an early Harmonix title.
And as I was playing
it I was like,
oh, I think people make these.
Like, I don't think
games just happen.
I think somebody makes them.
And I realized that was-- I
lived up on the North Shore,
so it was close, and I just
started pestering Harmonix
to hire me since I was close.
And they kept telling me no
until eventually I just got
a friend there who sort of
said nice things about me,
which was lovely of him, and
that sort of got me in in QA.
QA, I'm hesitant to say
that that's a good way
to start in the industry
anymore because I don't
know if it's quite as valid.
QA teams have gotten smaller
and the turnover is a little bit
difficult, so it's not
necessarily the entryway
into the industry
that it used to be,
which I do think is
a bit unfortunate.
I worked as a QA person on
the Karaoke Revolution series
early on and then on
the Guitar Hero series
before I end up becoming
a technical artist, which
meant that I wasn't a
programmer or an artist
but I helped make them have less
fights with each other, which
is probably something you guys
are used to at this point.
So I did a lot of
that and learned how
to animate and hook things up.
But then they realized-- one
of the things I was doing
was-- so Harmonix, I don't
know how familiar you
guys are with
Harmonix's [INAUDIBLE],
but this was before
Harmonix got bought by MTV.
And Guitar Hero had come out,
but that handled by RedOctane
and Activision-- RedOctane,
then Activision--
and we had an outside PR
place handle a lot of the PR.
And mostly we just made
games and put them out there
and there wasn't as much of a
consideration for us doing PR
from inside.
But we realized as we
wanted to make Rock Band
and we're moving away
from Guitar Hero and kind
of owning our own destiny that
we were the ones who were going
to have to talk up our own games
and kind of create something
about it.
So I wasn't the best technical
artist, I'll be honest.
So they moved me over to
running the community.
From Frequency and
Amplitude, there
was a very small
community of I'm
going to say about 50 or 60
people on the Harmonixfreak.com
forums and I was only one
willing to talk to them pretty
much in the whole company.
So as part of my job
is technical artist,
for an hour each day
I would sit and talk
with people on
the forums and try
to manage that community,
which was very, very small
and very angry that there
wasn't a sequel to Frequency
or Amplitude, that that
was kind of a dead series.
So a lot of my time
was spent apologizing,
I guess is how I would-- that
my big start to community
management was apologies.
So I did that for a while.
And when it came up
that we were going
to have to start
doing our own stuff,
I got promoted up to create
the community development
team at Harmonix.
And I put that
together, and that's
when there's a big change
because then we're owned by MTV
and they have a lot of
money-- like, a lot of money.
And they put a lot of money
into advertising for the game
and sending us around to,
like, every event and stuff.
I went to the Grammys
and was giving out
Rock Band to Morris Day and the
Time and weird stuff like that.
And it started moving
a little bit away
from just general
apologizing, daily dealing
with problems, and more
with kind of creating,
or at least sustaining,
a cult of personality
around the persona
of Harmonix, which
was sort of punk rock and
kind of outside of-- it
wasn't as much like
traditional game development.
Everybody there was a musician
and there was actually
kind of this identity
that we could
point to and kind of
play that up and make
that sort of the
character of the company.
And we definitely did that.
We played that up and because
one of the things-- and we'll
get into that more when
I talk a little bit more
about the difference between
marketing for AAA verses
marketing for indie-- is
a lot of games in AAA,
you're selling the games.
As far as marketing goes,
For indie, what
you're doing is you're
selling the people
who make the games,
and Harmonix was in
this interesting place
where even though
it was owned by MTV,
it worked a lot more
like an indie company.
So once we were able
to promote ourselves,
we promoted the company
as a group of people.
Like, don't just buy
Rock Band by Harmonix.
Buy the whole company.
Buy what we do.
Stick with us
because we're going
to keep making cool stuff.
And I did that for
a number of years
and it was crazy-- flew
constantly everywhere,
stayed in hotels that
didn't have lice and stuff.
It was nice.
A lot of getting to
do really cool things.
I ended up getting
sick after that
and spent a few years
away from the industry.
And when I came back,
I'd been playing
so many independent games
from small indie teams--
things like stuff that John Blow
had made or Fez or just a lot
of the games-- Castle
Crashers, Alien
Hominid, those sorts of games.
And I realized there was an
analog to what I was already
doing with Harmonix, which was
kind of the-- in indie games,
you really do have
to sell the artist.
You're selling the artist.
You're trying to
get people to come
because if you don't have an
interesting story in a way
or that you can sell to
the press or to journals,
you're not going to get anybody
writing articles about you
for the most part.
That's just the case.
The big AAA companies have
lots and lots of money
so they can plant lots
and lots of articles.
And as far as indie
stuff goes, the only way
you can sell yourself
is having a good story
that a journalist wants to tell
because if you don't have that,
there's really no
upside for them
to write an article
about you or your game
or anything like that.
I know that seems a little
cynical, but there it is.
That is the case.
So let's see-- so when
I went to Fire Hose,
the differences in the
marketing, like I said,
was when I was at
Harmonix, a lot
of what I did in community
management was making
sure everybody was really
invested in the product,
in ourselves as a team.
But a lot of it was also
keeping our secrets--
making sure that people
weren't leaking information
from inside of the
company, making
sure play testers weren't
leaking inside of the company,
making sure an unannounced
project that a coder on there
didn't go in and update their
LinkedIn profile and say,
hey, we're working on
Rock Band 2 at the time
before we'd announced
Rock Band 2,
and then there's a huge thing.
So a lot of my
stuff was managing
what information got out.
In independent games,
my job is to make sure
all of the information gets
out and that we are constantly
screaming for people to
notice us because there's
so much competition.
I mean, just look
at the explosion
of independent games
in the past let's say
five years, six years.
2008 I think is
really when it really
started becoming this definitive
thing that you can point at.
There's a lot of people,
and a lot of people
who also equally want people
to pay attention to them,
and there's only so
many outlets and there's
only so many places
where people are going
to be able to read about it.
So you're really fighting.
There is a sort of-- it
could very easily turn
into a sort of crabs in
the bucket situation,
just everybody pulling
each other down.
Luckily that's not really how
the indie game scene works.
A lot of people are trying
to push each other up,
which is nice, but
you're still competing
with so many other people
for a limited amount of slots
of articles.
The one thing I've learned
since I've been at Fire Hose
is that actually matters
very little if in the end--
and by that, I should
say I mean that
in terms of sales of the game.
A big article on
Kotaku isn't going
to sell your game, not anymore.
When I first started
in the industry,
that absolutely was the case.
A big article in GameSpot
or IGN, one of the big-- 1UP
at the time-- that
would put you over.
That could definitely
help put you over.
But at this point, that's
just simply not the case.
And even a year ago,
I was saying that,
and that everybody
should probably
put more of their marketing
time towards getting YouTube
people to cover their games.
And now that's sort of
the predominant theory,
but I think that's
going away, too,
because everybody who likes
games has a YouTube channel
and does Let's Plays.
So in a way, it's sort of
a reflection of what indie
is doing at the same time.
Now that there's
just so many people,
the market sort of flooded.
The novelty has worn off.
So it certainly can
help, but it's something
you have to be careful, too.
You can't put all of
your eggs in one basket.
But with indie, too-- so
when I was at Harmonix,
I ran a team of I think
at our height 12 people.
So that was 12 people doing
just community management
and just doing public relations.
At Fire Hose, I do that, all
of it, and I'm also a designer.
So it's like a part
of my overall job
and I'm the only one doing it.
So I have to choose what
we do far more carefully
and I have to do it without
any money whatsoever.
Certainly you can put money
into buying ads or doing
Facebook ads or
that sort of thing,
but I don't think that
that's necessarily the best
use of your time all the time.
And a lot of companies
don't have the budget
beyond their salaries to
actually buy these ads,
so what do you do?
And that goes back
to what I was saying.
It's community
management, and I guess
I should get into a
little bit of what
community management is.
When I started doing
community management in 2007,
it wasn't a thing really.
I think there was one
video game company that
wasn't an MMO, that didn't
make MMOs, that actually
had anything approaching
a community team,
and that was BioWare.
Right around Neverwinter
Nights, they put together
a community team of
two people, I think,
and that was just to
manage their forums.
And let's see, that's
probably around 2002/2003.
And in that time, you
really only put together
a community team if you
had a large multiplayer
game, generally an MMO.
So at the time, Asheron's Call
had something or Ultima Online
had it and early
World of Warcraft all
had these community teams.
There was an element
of promotion to it.
of marketing to it,
but it wasn't so much that.
It was more customer service.
They were really there
to deal with problems
that came up as they went.
BioWare where they sort of broke
the mold a little bit was it
wasn't about that.
It really was about the
company having direct access
to communicate with their
fans, and vice versa.
I once was half-joking
that my job as a community
manager at Harmonix
was ombudsman
because I felt like
I had to represent
the company to the
fans, and then I
had to represent the fans
to the company, which
involved being as
honest as possible
at all times with both, which
is a real difficult tightrope
to walk.
So with community management,
what you try to do
is you try to build out the
people who love your games.
You're trying to make
them into the people who
talk about your games online.
You're basically creating
a kind of an ad hoc sales
force, a word of
mouth way of promoting
your game because that's like if
you read an article on Kotaku,
do you immediately go
out and buy a game?
Probably not.
You might do a little
bit more research on it.
You might read up a
little bit more on it.
You might go to Metacritic
and check the reviews,
that sort of thing.
But if a friend tells
you, like just a person
you know is like, "Hey,
I'm checking out this game.
There might be multiplayer.
We should check
this out," you're
far more likely to buy it.
Community management is the
art of managing word of mouth.
You're getting people
to tell their friends,
the people that they know.
You're getting people to tell
the people who trust them
that this game is good so
that those people then go on
and buy it.
And join your community,
hopefully, and then they go on
and tell.
So what started for Harmonix, a
lot of what we did is because--
and there's a
scalability aspect to it.
When I created the Rock
Band community site,
that was 100% forums-based.
We did Twitter.
We did Facebook.
Like I said, we did
tons of live events,
but everything was very much
based around the forums.
Part of that was because
Twitter hasn't happened yet,
or was just happening
and not as many people
were talking about it.
This was early 2007.
So everything we did, we
build our this huge site.
We had forums.
I think I was
managing at that time
a registered community of about
350,000 people on the forums,
and that's why we needed a team.
It was big.
And there was an aspect
of customer service.
You might remember-- I
don't know how many of you
guys were really playing
that at the time,
but when it first
came out, there
were issues and articles
about the issues
about the instruments.
Any time you debut new
hardware, there's generally
going to be problems or
there's going to be issues,
and that happens.
So leading up to
it, it was very much
like, Rock Band's
going to be awesome.
We're doing rock.
And then as soon as it came
out and those issues started
coming up, the job just clamped
down into 100% customer service
all the time, just trying
to manage all of that.
Which was something that
having come from technical,
I wasn't necessarily
prepared to do.
But I think with any
game, no matter who
your audience is,
no matter what,
it's very valuable to have some
sort of protocol for customer
service leading up to it.
That's something I think that
you should definitely do.
At Fire Hose, we
don't have forums.
We have a Facebook page.
We have Twitter.
But forums, they're not
what they used to be.
The communities aren't
forums, aren't the same
as they used to be,
and sometimes they're
just more trouble than
they're worth to manage.
It could be it's
very time-consuming
to stop all the spam, to
get in the middle of fights
and stop people from
hurting each other.
And we were very hands-on.
We weren't a
website where it was
like, say whatever you want.
Post whatever you want.
We were very hands-on about
abuse and that sort of thing.
At Fire Hose since we don't
have as big of an audience--
we don't have 350,000 people
who are following what we're
doing who are registered
users who are going to follow
everything that we
say and everything
that we do and are
really hugely invested
in the company or our games--
so we have to find other ways.
One of the things that's
probably the biggest thing-- I
should bring this up here-- is
we started up a Twitch channel,
and this was just as the
live video and live streaming
was starting to
really become a thing.
So it was a couple years ago.
We had Go Home Dinosaurs,
which you might
have seen on the scroller.
That was a game that
we put out last year.
That was coming out and we
wanted to get attention for it.
And we realized we
wouldn't be able to get
every the YouTube video star
to feature our dumb game that
was awesome-- it was awesome--
about dinosaurs stealing
barbecue from early mammals.
We knew we weren't going to get
every YouTube star to cover it.
TotalBiscuit did
actually, somehow,
but we realized we kind of
had to build our own community
and really kind of make
our own press for it
rather than spend
all of my time.
Our marketing
budget is my salary.
There's not extra
stuff where I'm
buying up ads and everything.
So we started
meeting with Twitch.
Actually, they came
out here to talk
about how they wanted to get
more indie games on there
and we sort of struck up
a relationship with people
at Twitch, and that got
us front page promotions.
So for instance every
day, Monday through Friday
from 12:00 to 12:30
on Twitch, you
will see my big stupid
face staring out
at you from the screen because
we're on the front page
right in the thing, and
anybody who goes to Twitch
is going to see our game first.
That cost us absolutely
zero dollars.
As far as budget
goes, all that takes
is my time because
we talk to them
and we try to create
good content that also
helps their brand, as well.
But that brings us-- you can
see so far since we started up
our channel, four million
people have watched it.
Four million impressions is
way outside of our price range.
It's just outside of our--
that would be tens of thousands
of dollars to get that
many people to get
an impression of our product, to
get an impression of Fire Hose,
to get an impression
of our games,
to get an impression of the
people who worked there.
It would take that long,
and part of the way we do
is like I said, every day,
Monday through Friday 12:00
to 12:30, I put on a show.
It's about Let's Quip!
That's actually my game.
I should mention
Fire Hose, we have
three games going right now.
We also do outside projects.
We take on contract work.
Right now we're working
on a project with DARPA
that's pretty cool that
actually teaches people not
to shoot people.
It's pretty fun.
But we have three eventually
commercially available products
that we're working on right now.
One is Let's Quip!
That's a game I'm designing.
That's a comedic debating game.
That's what I do
on the show Monday
to Friday 12:00 to 12:30.
Just I invite local
comedians in and we just
talk about different aspects of
comedy while playing the game,
and that has actually
been wildly successful.
I had Jackie Kashian,
who's a very big touring
comedian who I'm a huge fan of.
She came in on the show.
And on that show, I think,
over the course of that one
half-hour, we had
something-- I want
to say it was 24,000
people, which is great.
Like I said, I would not
be able to pay for that.
I would not be able
to afford that.
But all it takes is my time.
We also have three
other shows that we do.
So there's the Monday show.
So that's 2 and 1/2
hours out of the week.
And then we have a Tuesday
show in the afternoon
from 4:00 to 5:00.
That's one of the other
games that we're working on.
Chris Chung, who's
a local developer,
he's working on a game
called Catlateral Damage
that you may have heard of.
Catlateral Damage is
really, really rad.
You're basically a cat.
It has first-person
shooter controls.
Your family's left the
house for a little while,
so you have a limited
amount of time
to just destroy
all of their stuff.
And it's great.
You're just pouncing around
knocking things on the floor.
You get points for
destroying people's monitors.
It's great.
It's exactly what cats do.
It's very, very fun, and
Chris is this lovely guy.
He loves cats in a way
that's sort of very honest.
There's nothing
ironic about, and he's
kind of the perfect person
to host a show about making
a game about cats.
So we gave him this spot, 4:00
to 5:00, where all he does
is he sits there with Unity
open and he shows what
he's been working on that week.
And he tells people, like,
we do this, we do this.
I just added in these things.
This is how I did that in Unity.
So it's one part demonstration
of his game and one part
tutorial, and that
brings in people, too--
people who want to learn
more about making video games
as well as people who are just
interested in a game about cats
knocking your stuff over.
And that really works
for him, and it really
fits the theme of this game.
The other game we have is a
game called 20XX, which we just
announced two weeks ago.
If you are a fan of
games like Mega Man X
or those sorts of
platformers, it's a game very
much similar to that.
We're working with a team
out of I believe Maryland.
It's where they
currently reside.
So part of that is we-- I
should clarify that Fire Hose
Games late last year as
opposed to just a studio,
we opened up an incubator
for independent games.
So for the most part,
local indie game developers
who have good games that
they really want to work on
can come to Fire hose,
get a monthly stipend,
get office space,
and we'll help them
with the development
of the game.
We'll help them with the
promotion of the game.
We help them with
kind of everything.
And it's more like
a partnership.
Both Catlateral Damage and
20XX are part of that program.
And it's great working because
that's like Catlateral Damage
and 20XX and Let's
Quip! are three
incredibly different games.
Like I said, 20XX has a very
sort of Mega Man X feel.
It's very hardcore.
It's very platformery.
Catlateral Damage is
about cats, so that
has a completely
different audience.
I'm sure on a Venn diagram,
there's some crossover.
And then Let's
Quip! is just a game
where you write words down.
Like you write
tweets and then you
try to be funnier
than other people.
The three games have almost no
shared audience across them,
so we have to approach
everything very,
very differently.
I think showing Let's Quip!
but actually showing comedians
playing it, that helps
because that actually
plays into the
narrative of the game,
the fiction of the game, which
is allowing you to be funny.
And then we have
comedians come in
and kind of vote on
whether you're funny
or not, and that's creating
sort of a cult of personality.
And at the same time, they're
also meeting the creators.
So like I said earlier
when I was talking
about how people pushing the
artist as opposed to the art,
we sort of play into
that a little bit.
Having Chris Chung come in
and just show development
on [INAUDIBLE], it's so earnest.
If you get a chance,
you should really
watch it because he's just the
most likable, smart dude who's
just going through.
And for a live stream where he
just basically has Unity open
and he's just moving
things around,
he gets several thousand people
over the hour watching him,
which is nuts.
But it's great.
People love it.
With 20XX, we've just started.
I'm just working
on the marketing
plan for that, the marketing map
for the next six months or so.
And I should say that's when I'm
just planning out this month,
these are the things
we need to talk to.
We need this many screenshots.
We need to have a
trailer for February.
We need to have this.
And just coming up with those
milestones in the same way
that I'm sure you come
up with your milestones
for your project.
We're doing the same thing,
but on the marketing end.
These are the goals we
need to hit in December.
These are the people we
need to talk to in January.
If we can get an
exclusive for February,
that means we're going to
need to be talking about it
in December and have
a pitch for that,
have some sort of
PowerPoint presentation
or just a really good email
with good resource screenshots
and videos and stuff that we can
send out to different outlets
to try to get a little
bit of coverage.
Even though I said
that articles don't
have a direct effect
on sales, they
do have a direct
effect on zeitgeist,
I guess I should say, so there
is a sort of cultural cachet
that comes from having a big
article on your games there.
It doesn't necessarily
translate to sales.
But if you know how to
use it and take advantage
of that cultural cachet, you
can bring more people in,
which I find useful.
But every single one
of these games, I
have to market differently
because they're
marketed to different people.
Like I said, 20XX, also that
game is going to be on Steam.
It's I think it was
$14.99, and that game
we put out in early access.
That's one of the
early ways we're
trying to market it is
getting it out on early access
and getting people who are
excited about Mega Man-style
platformers really
talking about that game
and very excited
about that game.
Whereas with Let's Quip!, that's
just going to comedy fans.
All I'm doing is talking to
comedians for the most part
because comedians if
they like the game,
they're going to
tweet about the game.
And it turns out comedians have
lots of fans who like comedy.
Who would've thought?
And then with Catlateral
Damage, as far as I can tell,
the audience for that game
is every person on Earth.
It involves cats.
It involves mindless
destruction.
It's everything the world
is asking for right now.
It's just beautiful and I love
Chris and I love the game.
It's amazing.
But since in a way
that's a little bit more
of a mainstream game, that also
takes a completely different
approach because we're
not selling that game
to hardcore gamers.
Hardcore gamers are
certainly invited,
but this is a game that
I can give to my mom
or I could give to a friend
who already likes video games,
and both could get
something out of that.
And that takes a
different approach
because you don't want
to come up with a-- like,
I wouldn't want to
come up with an ad
or a promo for the game
that was like, this
is the baddest game ever.
It's going to destroy your life.
I'm not going to be
advertising that way
because that'll turn
off the people who
are not hardcore gamers.
They're not going
to want to play
something that acts like
it's going to destroy them.
Whereas also if you go too
soft on the other side,
that's going to turn
off other people.
So you're going to find sort
of a midway line between that,
and that's another thing
I'm working on right now
with Chris.
But as far as video
goes on Twitch,
I think that's
very, very helpful.
I should probably start getting
ready to take questions,
I think.
But I guess one of the
things you asked me, too,
is about IGF in the IndieCade.
For me, it's a hard thing
because I do certainly
find value in marketing for as
far as award shows and stuff,
like the IGF getting awards.
I personally have a whole lot
of problems with the whole
how awards for any art.
I guess I think I just
have personal problems.
I think it's very,
very valuable.
And I think especially
for young developers
who are trying to
their name out there,
getting your game into as many
festivals as possible is great.
Don't break the bank doing so.
A lot of them require
submission fees.
So if you can find festivals
that fit the genre of the game,
just do your research.
Know what you're submitting to.
Like IGF has something like
7,000 people submitting
every year, and that costs
money for you to submit.
So if you think you can
compete, definitely do it.
Otherwise, put your efforts
into a different festival
which still you
could win something
and then you can put
that on everything
that you market the game with.
Like, the winner of
the 1989-- I don't
know why I went with 1989.
I'm old.
So, yeah.
You just put that
award on there.
I'm sure you've been
on Steam and you've
seen they have a section where
you can actually just put links
to every award you've
got, and then it shows up
and there's a little graphic.
That's really good and that
can get your name out there.
And even though I have
a problem with it,
I can still see the value in it.
IndieCade is one of the funnest
things I've ever been to.
And every time I get really
down on this industry, which
happens, going to
IndieCade makes
me remember why I love working
with the people I love.
I love this industry,
and I love the weird crap
that people come up with because
it's a great place for games
that were completely outside the
mainstream to exist and live.
That's how I found out
about this game last year
called Dominique Pamplemousse.
I don't know if any
of you have played it.
It's a musical.
It's an opera game, which
is adventure singing.
It's nuts and it's
great, but people never
would have found out about it
if it weren't for just winning
the IGF Award, for
noticing weirder games that
are outside the
mainstream like that.
But I think I should open things
up for questions if anybody
has anything specific.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned about
how articles don't directly
translate [INAUDIBLE].
Do you think that's also
starting to be true for AAA,
or is it more of a
direct [INAUDIBLE]
expect to get [INAUDIBLE]?
SEAN BAPTISTE: I
think there's probably
still some value to
for AAA, and part
of that is because the one thing
that's great about being a AAA
developer is you have resources,
and lots and lots of resources.
So one of the things we
would do any time you
talk about the launch
of a game, it'd be like,
OK, so let's say
Assassin's Creed.
The next one supposed to come
out on September 9, 2015.
You want to own that
Newsday, and that
means you are planting
articles on it for September 8
and September 9 at every
outlet in the world
so that that day when every
person who checks video game
blogs, reads a video game
blog, the only thing they're
going to be reading
about is your game.
It's basically like
playing a commercial
on a loop for an entire day
until you've subliminally
made that person buy your game.
That's sort of the whole idea.
Independence-- we
cannot own a Newsday.
It's very difficult because it's
expensive and time-consuming--
really, really
time-consuming to own
a Newsday as an independent
because just planting
one major article in a big
thing, like say a cover
article for GameInformer--
that's so many
man hours between the person
who's negotiating that deal
and making it happen, coming up
with a story like the narrative
for the game you're
trying to sell.
Plus also art resources,
like getting your artists
to deliver a whole
bunch of screenshots,
but also Photoshops of
all of the characters.
That's so expensive
in time and money,
and indies can't do that.
So I think for us,
we can get articles.
But really getting an article
in everything simultaneously
on the same day-- the funniest
thing that ever happened
is when Go Home
Dinosaurs came out,
I was sending review
codes out to things.
And I was like, so we
have an embargo for this,
and one reporter literally wrote
back, Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
We don't have that.
We don't have the
muscle to be like,
we can back up this embargo.
AAA places have a hard
time backing up an embargo,
but they have the benefit
of being like, well,
if you don't adhere
to this embargo,
we're not going to give you
coverage of the next game.
Whereas if you're an indie,
you would be cutting your nose
off right there.
Like, fine, you don't
get to do the next game,
and they'll tell you
won't have a next game.
So like I said,
there's certainly
cultural cachet I
think for indies,
but it's more valuable for AAA.
AUDIENCE: So
community management
as you described it is a word
of mouth deal for a lot of it.
Is part of your
purview then doing
bundle sales and other types of
sales where if you get somebody
to play the game, maybe
they'll talk to somebody
else about the game?
SEAN BAPTISTE: Yeah.
Doing bundle sales--
see, that's another one
I'm torn on because I see
the value in bundles sales,
but I see that that value
is diminishing day by day.
There are so many
bundles out there,
Humble Bundle being
one of the biggest.
But then there's, like, 70
other ones that you can go to.
And Humble Bundle's
great to work
with because they're very
protective of the Steam keys
that you put out, whereas a
lot of the other bundle places,
they don't have
as much security.
So what happens is you put
your thing in a bundle.
That bundle sells 10,000.
You get $0.13 on the dollar for
whatever people paid, or less.
Probably less--
probably much less.
But you're not getting
that much money.
You're selling at a discount
to try to get a huge amount.
The thing is what a lot of
the people buying those are,
they're overseas.
And what they're
doing is they're not
buying the game because
they're fan of you or your game
or they want to play it
or your game was just one
other thing in the bundle.
They're buying up
Steam keys and then
they are selling them on
their own sites overseas.
So basically they're buying
your game and 15 other games
for $5.00 total in the bundle,
and then they're selling all
of those at half
off of retail price.
And that cuts into
your sales so bad
because when people actually
do want to play your game,
they're looking for a deal.
So they end up going to
this off-brand site that's
selling Steam codes
from it, and it's rough.
There's a lot of indies who've
shot themselves in the foot
by going to Bundle
Crazy and then
really killing the long tail
on their sales in my opinion.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: How big an
impact did TotalBiscuit
have on Go Home Dinosaur sales?
SEAN BAPTISTE: I think a few
more people found out about it.
I don't think it had
on sales, not much.
Not much.
And even at the
time, that was when
that was sort of happening.
And it wasn't the most glowing
play-through of all time
that he's ever played
it, but he liked
it and he said it was
really fun and dumb, which
is what we were going for.
But in the end as
far sales goes,
it wasn't as big of a
driver as one would think.
I do know of games
that TotalBiscuit
has covered that has had a
pronounced effect on sales,
but they're multiplayer games.
Like our game, it
was single-player.
Whereas if you have
a multiplayer shooter
or if you have something
like Hearthstone,
a game where people are
playing together online,
that's his audience.
His audience does
care about e-sports
and does care about
big multiplayer games,
and ours wasn't that.
So I don't know if
that was necessarily
the best fit, but still
nice that he liked it,
nice that he played it.
Oh, yeah?
Go ahead.
No problem.
AUDIENCE: Do you also
manage the Steam forums
for any of the games, or
do you solely do just--
SEAN BAPTISTE: I do you manage
the Steam forums a little bit,
mostly for customer
service because that
would be the first
place people would
go rather than emailing us.
We had a link inside the game
where people could email us
if they had problems,
if there were
bugs or something like that.
[INAUDIBLE]. [INAUDIBLE].
But a lot of people went
straight to the Steam forums
and would talk about
their problems on there
and do direct sort of stuff.
But as far as building
up the community there,
some games work for that
and some games don't.
I think games that
are multiplayer
just do better as far as
Steam forum communities.
It's just easier to grow
a community like that,
build a community there.
But where for
single-player games,
people are less interested
in, I think, talking
to other people about them.
Maybe Skyrim, that sort
of a single-player game
where there's a huge expansive
world and there's more to share
and it's less
linear, I think there
might be more room for
community on Steam.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
about IndieCade as an event
[INAUDIBLE] rejuvenation.
On Monday, we had Jenna come in.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
She was talking about how
she spends so much on events.
And I'm wondering how
do events factor in
and how you think about events
in terms of sales, in terms
of [INAUDIBLE]?
SEAN BAPTISTE: So events
are difficult for indies
because events by their
very nature cost money
to travel to, to stay at.
Luckily the
independent community
is great because we'll just
call up 19 other companies
and be like, hey, you
guys are going to this?
Cool.
Want to get an Airbnb?
And then we just share it
and try to keep costs down,
but it's still expensive.
You can't do that for a
flight or to get places.
Well, you might be able to.
You shouldn't.
But I will say this-- if
you can go to an event,
if there's any conceivable
way you can go to an event,
and I mean just
about any event where
there's other game
developers there talking
about games, any sort of
game-based conference or expo,
go to it.
Absolutely go to it.
I've been talking
about word of mouth.
One of the best ways
of word of mouth
is going out and meeting
other developers who
have other communities
supporting their games--
talking to them
about their game,
you talking about your
game, and just sort
of sharing because
then they are going
and they're going to be
probably be, hey, check out
this new friend I made.
He's making this game
and it's pretty cool.
And you're getting more
people noticing it.
And it's better to be part of
the overall game development
community than it is
to be outside of it.
But by the same token,
sometimes you just
don't want to talk to
people, and that's fair, too.
AUDIENCE: Actually, it
made me think, in the past,
did you play other people's
games on your FireHost?
SEAN BAPTISTE: Yeah,
I should mention that.
So when we first started
out, like I mentioned,
we did it because we
wanted to sell Go Home
Dinosaurs and another game that
we had made a port of it called
Slam Bolt Scrappers.
And so we started off with that,
and it became very apparent
after two weeks that
we only had two games,
and that's not a good show.
That's not a great show.
So that was our Wednesday show.
That was our inaugural show
on our live stream channel.
So after those two weeks, we
were like, what else can we do?
We shouldn't give up
on this because we
don't have two games.
How do we build
our audience more?
And then we were like, what if
we played other people's games?
And then we realized, well, what
if we bring in other developers
and then they bring in
their games with them?
And then we play their
games while they're
standing next to us, and
then we just talk about it?
And I have a
standing desk at work
and it's just two of us standing
there and playing games.
And we just interview and
talk to them about the game
that they made while
we're playing it.
And I've called that sharing.
You create it, you bring
your own spotlight,
and then you share it.
And that helps.
We help get other,
smaller-- because we
don't do a lot of big games.
It's very rare.
We did Super Smash
Brothers, I think
is the biggest game, the biggest
marketable game, that we've
had on our live
stream, and that's
just because everybody at
the office is addicted to it.
But largely, we have
other people in.
Like in January, we
had Zoe Quinn in.
We had people before
that, like just a bunch
of other developers throughout
the country because sometimes
they couldn't come in, so
we'd have them Skype in.
And it's helped
them, but it also
helps us because it gives
us content for our show.
It helps give them exposure
and it helps build our audience
over time because they're
tuning into an exciting show.
And watching game developers
talk about game development
and seeing that sort of inside
baseball is for some reason
exciting to people.
I don't know why,
but there's something
that people enjoy
tuning into about it.
PROFESSOR: Anyone else
have comments, question?
All right.
Thank you so much for coming.
SEAN BAPTISTE: All right.
Thank you very
much for having me.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
Good luck on your
projects this week.
I look forward to seeing them.
PROFESSOR: Are you going to
be able to just stick around
for a little bit, or
you have to run off?
SEAN BAPTISTE: Yeah,
I'll be around.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
So if anybody wants
to talk to him now,
feel free to come on
down and talk to him.
We're going to break
for about 10 minutes.
Come down and sign up.
Other thing I should
note-- [INAUDIBLE]
is coming today at around 2:30
to talk to some of the teams
if you want to talk to her.
If you have burning
questions about your game
that you need to get answered by
one of our clients, she's here
and available to talk you.
Otherwise, the rest the
class period is for yourself.
[CHATTER]